thank you
[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanut
peanuts Tommy this is a big day
this is the day that you can create
history for yourself land yourself in
the record books no one here expects you
to win no one thinks anything of you
they think you're a hat trick some
parlor trick that that we got through
the money that we earned through a
stupid podcast but here's where you
prove them wrong here's
where you stand in the sand and fight
them all by yourself you are the Key to
Greatness every child that is overweight
and thinks nothing of themselves and
doesn't get picked on a sports team is
going to look at you and want your
jersey Tommy
we've got hundreds of middle American
average human beings rooting for me and
you it is you that will carry my dreams
into history I need you to hold on to
that wheel tight I need you to take that
right foot I need you to hold it down
and press it until you can't press it
any further until you feel the tarmac
and Tommy when I tell you you need a pit
stop I want you to ignore me tell me
boss I'm going off on my own
[__] Bush Tommy it's too bad racing
forever
God Tom Segura and Burke Chrysler were
broadcasting live from the Daytona
International Speedway yesterday as part
of a very special episode of two bears
one cave that took place in front of
fans at the Daytona 500. give it up for
all three
[Applause]
oh
yeah
that's how we shake off Daytona
everybody Burton Tom technically do have
more of a history in competitive racing
than you might think they've been
talking about forming two bears Racing
for over a year now it started off as
Kind of a Funny concept idea but things
really got serious last April when Bert
gifted Tom an actual race car for his
birthday tell Tom what he got
oh I'm so glad he finally has his car
what a pain in the ass
[Laughter]
Tom happy birthday thank you very much I
am very I'm very happy that you guys
asked me to be part of this it's really
really fun
um and the number of people that have
emailed me trying to get a job on this
fake race team is truly truly comical
[Laughter]
uh I'm like you know this is a fake race
team right
so so
what E46 race car okay it's called a
spec E46 I always assume they were kind
of joking about two bears racing even
after Tom got a real race car I was like
wow they're really committing to this
bit but now it seems like it could be
more of a real thing Tom has a passion
for the sport they're well connected
with drivers and coaches and they're
already getting a foot in the door with
NASCAR fans I'm excited to be here
because I feel like this is our first
Venture into
two bears racing it is our first bench
in the two bears racing uh we were gonna
have
um three drivers stop by but they all
decided to pull out but uh I know they
don't want to be a part of the team but
what do you want to assign somebody
while we're here you want to try I would
like to okay I'll tell you right now
here's my pitch I look what black rifles
doing Travis pastrano yeah and we're
trying to Pastrana's doing and having
him in this race is in my opinion by the
way I know nothing about NASCAR but it
may makes it the most accessible
NASCAR's ever been in my opinion since
Danica Patrick I feel like Travis
Pastrana being in this race all of a
sudden is all us generation that grew up
on MTV watching him race we're like all
of a sudden we're like oh man our guy's
in it is that you know what I mean and
so I feel like I'm not even joking in
five years I think two bears racing can
be contenders in the Daytona 500. I
from this comedy career and focus on
your racing out of all the podcast and
all the comedians in the world this is
the perfect Duo to go live from the
Daytona 500. I feel like Burton Tom
fitting great with the entire Vibe of
NASCAR especially this race right I
really feel like you're in your element
here a lot of burnt look-alikes out
there how you guys doing
I feel like I feel like I feel like I'm
looking in a mirror
I feel like the whole city is your
mirror I feel like
definitely possible definitely possible
look you got a willing oh wow a female
all right
it's usually guys how's it going ma'am
if you can fall in love with one of us
quicker who do you think it would be oh
I have a guest Gillian keeves the
special became available for the first
time on Prime video Google Play and
Apple tv five days ago the special first
came out last October on Gillian keeves
website and includes 10 total sketches
along with onstage performances from
Shane Gillis and John McKeever we're
basically going to show you guys a bunch
of sketches we'll come back out we'll
chat are you a middle-aged Italian man
that just moved out of his parents house
I bet you didn't but let's say you did
the government used people with Philly
accents to torture uh terrorists
overall it's always exciting to see an
independent show like Gillian keeves
getting more mainstream recognition now
that it's available on three very
popular streaming platforms they'll be
able to hit a whole new audience of
potential fans or Shane Gillis said now
available for the geezers guest spots
from last week your mom's house did not
have a guest two bears one cave was Bert
and Dana Carvey kill Tony tonight is Jim
Florentine Eddie pepitone and Punky
Johnson flagrant head on Ralph Barbosa
Big Jay oakerson who on the Honeydew
Mike Cannon was on are you garbage and
bad friends was Bobby Stevie weeby Peter
Kim and dumbfounded
I love it dude stay on them you're doing
great terrible dude I I don't know if
this chemistry of four Koreans in a room
for podcasting works it doesn't work
it's working right now oh it's working
now oh it's working no we're talking
over here in a good way it's working
whoever wants to talk could go like this
no there's no room and let me say
something to you Mike right you can't
come in here with agendas skits like
is this scissor Brothers oh do you want
to eat you want to eat hot peppers
nut sacks to a wall all right no this
isn't scissor Brothers
we speak the truth here this past
weekend with the Yvonne had on Laney
Wilson Dan Soder and Lamar Lee were on
Matt and Shane's secret podcast Sal
vulcano was on take her shoes off with
Rick Glassman we might be drunk head on
nape or gazi Rick Glassman was on the
Harland Highway jazz on the Christy KS
podcast Stuffy's World head on Jessica
Kirsten and Jim Jefferies is on
tigerbelly as far as new stand-up
specials go that have come out sooner
out right now there's a ton that I
forgot to talk about last week starting
off with Mark Maron from Bleak to dark
that's out right now on HBO Max and
according to their description legendary
comedian Mark Maron offers his take on
Grief getting older stupid people cats
and fascism in his first HBO Comedy
Special Jim Jeffery's high and dry came
out last week on Netflix as well that's
Jim Jeffery's fifth special on Netflix
in the last nine years there's also a
few specials coming out soon that we
should be looking forward to starting
off with Bert Kreischer Razzle Dazzle
they'll be available on Netflix starting
on March 14th and Big Jay oakerson shot
a special recently that's coming out on
April 5th 2023 so a lot of Comedy to
look forward to a lot of Comedy out
right now from some big names that does
it for this week's joke World comedy
news update as always thank you so much
for watching this video and we'll be
back again next Monday with some more
comedy news but in the meantime we're
going to be posting two more videos this
week including a full review of The Bert
Kreischer arena show that I went to this
weekend in his hometown that was amazing
so many cool things happened to that
show that I'm excited to talk to you
guys all about so make sure you keep
your eyes peeled for that video also
shout out to everyone who subscribed to
our second Channel clip world so far
seriously I appreciate all of you guys
who did that big thank you over there
we're gonna start posting way more
content over there probably two more
videos over there this week as well so a
lot to look out for a lot to look
forward to make sure you're subscribed
and locked into all the channels on joke
World here thank you again so much for
watching and have a great rest of your
week
foreign
[Music]